أنا دكتور سانجاي غوبتا ، مضيف بودكاست
Chasing Life على قناة CNN ،
غالبًا ما نتحدث عن التوازن العقلي ، لكنني
أردت قضاء دقيقة اليوم في الحديث
عن التوازن الجسدي الآخر ،
إنه أمر مهم حقًا مع تقدمك في العمر في الواقع ،
فالسقوط هو السبب الرئيسي لإصابة
الناس  65 عامًا فما فوق ، هناك
العديد من العوامل التي يمكن أن تؤثر على
حدودنا الجسدية ، تغير الرؤية الشيخوخة من
اللياقة البدنية بشكل عام ، وهذا
يعني أيضًا أن هناك أشياء يمكنك القيام بها
لتحسين توازنك ربما لم
تدركها ، على سبيل المثال مجرد البقاء على
قدميك بقدر ما  من الممكن الوقوف
بدلاً من الجلوس أيضًا ، شيء بسيط
يمكنك القيام به هو التدرب على الوقوف على ساق واحدة
والتأكد من أنك تقف بجوار
شيء يمكنك الإمساك به في حال
تعثرت بالسير في الطابق العلوي وتقوم بعمل القرفصاء
والاندفاع أيضًا جيدًا للحدود
وتأكد من أنك بانتظام  الانتقال من الجلوس إلى
الوقوف ، فهذه حركة أساسية
للحفاظ على الاستقلال مع تقدمك في العمر ،
أخيرًا ، تعتبر Tai Chi تمرينًا رائعًا
لجميع الأعمار من خلال أداء سلسلة من
الحركات البطيئة المتدفقة وتحويل
وزنك باستمرار لتحدي توازنك
وتحسين كثافة العظام واستقرار المفاصل.
حسنًا ،
يمكنك سماع المزيد حول كيفية
تحسين صحتك وحياة Chase
أينما حصلت على ملفاتك الصوتية